hola yo lo saludo desde la avenida
pensilvania esa por donde transita la
marcha a favor del aborto acá en
washington la alcaldía dio permiso para
que 17 mil personas salieran hoy a
manifestarse a favor del aborto y en
contra de la decisión que eventualmente
tomaría la corte suprema de justicia de
eeuu de prohibir el aborto esto a
principios de julio como se conoció a
partir de la información filtrada miles
de manifestantes sacan washington
entonces y en las principales ciudades
del país se calcula que hay 380 eventos
similares a este hoy en todo el país y
entonces esta marcha llegará hasta la
corte suprema donde se termina la esta
avenida pensilvania y allá para anne
este llamado a la acción por parte de
los magistrados de que por favor
protejan el derecho al aborto la corte
suprema de justicia está al frente del
capitolio donde también quieren
compartir este mensaje de proteger el
aborto después de que la semana pasada
precisamente se conociera que el senado
no va a tomar medidas para proteger el
aborto en eeuu casablanca ha dicho que
apoya este tipo de iniciativas este tipo
de marchas pero muchos analistas y
críticos dicen que ya es muy tarde y muy
poco lo que puede hacer el ejecutivo
teniendo en cuenta la resistencia que
hay en la corte suprema de justicia y en
el senado
[Música]